Why did this video get so many views?
The reason is simple. Tim was telling
stories of deliverance and living
overseas as a missionary. He seen plenty
of spiritual activity. Now, what he says
next about what happened while writing
his book. You're going to want to hear
that.
So I'm curious which one of these books
was the one that you had given to
somebody and they were reading it and
some very strange things started
happening.
Well the book that I was uh they were
reading is when sacrifice is gain.
Okay.
Oh that
so it wasn't the new book.
It wasn't the new book.
What's this one about? Because that's
interesting.
So when sacrifice is gain is about um
lessons I've learned from 40 odd years
in mission.
Uhhuh.
Yeah. And inside this book, there are a
number of stories of deliverance, people
having demons cast out of them.
I see.
So my senior high school students and
some of the junior high school students
were reading the book. We had it
translated into language so they could
understand it clearly. And
several of the girls came to me and
said, "Uh, since I started reading the
book, I'm having nightmares and demons
are harassing me. Uh and then uh one of
the great eight girls, she came to me
and said, "Can you pray for me since I
started reading the book? I'm having
nightmares. My I see my dead
grandfather."
What?
And he's telling me, "Don't read that
book."
Oh, weird.
Interesting.
And she keeps reading and then one night
I get a call from the dorm to say, "Uh,
she's possessed."
What? And so I go to the dorm and sure
enough she's there speaking with a male
voice and the male voice is saying don't
read the book.
We got like 30 dorm kids, dorm girls
around and they're all listening in. Uh
and they're joining in singing songs of
praise to God. Uh and the dawn dean was
there reading the Bible and I began
ordering the evil spirit out of her. Um
initially it appeared to pay no
attention
Yeah. to the name of Jesus. It just kept
on saying, "Do not read that book."
And then uh after about an hour of us
reading the Bible, singing praise to
God, and then ordering the evil spirit
out, it left her and she came conscious
again.
Wow. Um, and she she said it was a real
weird experience because it was like
there was herself and one other entity
in her body and the other entity was
preventing her from talking.
That's crazy.
Oh wow.
As as I could see the power of the evil
spirit weakening, I began saying to her,
um, say the name of Jesus. Ask Jesus to
help you. And she began to try to say
it, and the demon was preventing her.
But as she persisted, she began to say
the name of Jesus. And it was then that
she actually came came out and the demon
left.
That's pretty incredible. So these are
things that we have read about in the
Bible, similar things happening. But
you don't see it too often, at least not
in the United States. You don't see that
too often and you don't hear about it
too often, but it sounds like you see
this
somewhat
more often than we do. Now, the really
interesting thing with that is this girl
is a very spiritual girl.
Okay?
She prays every day. She reads her
Bible. She leads out a Sabbath school
class. And so, I'm questioning why was
she possessed,
right?
Um, and it was only a couple of weeks
ago when I did a dorm search at the
request of the dorm deans, I discovered
that she had a phone, a smartphone, and
we have a rule, no smartphones. and I
had actually confiscated one off her
earlier in the year
and she had replaced it. And so while
she's a good Christian girl, uh, in most
parts of her life, this is one area of
deception
where she was basically lying by having
a phone. And I guess that was the excuse
the demons could use to attack her.
So it was the it was more of the fact
that she had disobeyed one of the rules,
I think,
than it was the possession of the
smartphone.
Yes. Otherwise, there's probably a lot
of nervous people, right?
Well, I guess I'm also wondering if you
know, we don't know what she was
watching on her smartphone. This is
true. That's true. So, she might have
been watching some or listening to some
immoral things and
yeah, she could open the way.
She claimed she wasn't because I did ask
her that question, but uh she
she was breaking a rule and knowingly
breaking a rule as she'd already been
punished for breaking it once before.
Huh. And
and it's interesting that it was on a
second offense, not necessarily the
first one. Like she had been told there
was an opportunity for her to respond
and she responded in the negative
instead of the positive. And that's what
now I guess the upshot of the story was
that all these girls are hearing this
demon saying, "Don't read the book." And
that tweaked the interest for many of
them. So now they were more determined
than ever. What is it in the book that
the demons don't want them to know? They
weren't nervous about reading the book
because of what happened to her.
Some of them. Yes. Some of them were
like, "Okay, we want to know what's in
this book."
Interesting.
It sounds like the times of in the Bible
whenever you whenever they would kill a
Christian, you know, a bunch of other
Christians would arise from that out of
curiosity. Okay. Why was why was this
person killed for preaching the gospel?
Sounds like the same here. Like don't
read the book.
Why? Now I'm curious. Right. Have you
ever had that experience or a similar
experience or seen a similar experience
with someone who is reading a Bible
where they get possessed
and somebody is saying
don't read the book.
Don't read the book.
Uh many people have told me that when
they open the Bible to read it, their
mind gets like cloudy.
They're not able to concentrate. They
get sleepy.
Gotcha. um not actually being told not
to read the book, but just the demons
making it really hard to read.
Interesting. Okay. So, you wrote that
book. Several people have read it.
They've had experiences.
But since last year, you were on the
show last year. You wrote another book
called Fallen Angels.
Called Fallen Angels. Right. The uh one
man's true encounters with evil.
So, that's your story.
This is my story. This is many of the
stories we talked about last year on the
Little Light Studios podcast are in this
book. There are others as well, but I
elaborate more.
All right. So, if you haven't seen that
episode, make sure you check that out.
We'll either put it on the screen or put
definitely put a link in the description
below to check out the other episode we
did with Tim. So, has anybody read this
book and had similar experiences with
this one?
So far, nobody has. Not many people have
read this book because
Okay. Cuz it's just fresh off the press
last week.
Oh, okay.
But those that were helping proofread it
for me. Uh, and a couple of them have
said that God used it to highlight areas
in their lives that they needed to deal
with.
Oh, wow.
That's interesting. Okay.
I think it sounds like something
everybody should read then.
I think it'd be good reading.
You wrote it.
Yeah.
A little bit biased, but he's he's he's
definitely being humble about it, not
trying to sell it too hard. So,
well, I think it it opens people's eyes
to the demonic world and how that
interfaces with the human world.
Right. While most of my stories come out
of Asia, there are some out of
uh western countries, but I think much
of what is there is applicable. The
problem with places like the United
States, people don't want to talk about
it. They don't want to talk about what
the demons are saying to them, what the
demons are doing to them, because
they're going to get labeled crazy.
Yeah.
Or sent to a psychiatric ward.
Exactly.
And put on psychiatric meds.
And so it's happening, but we're not
they're just not talking about it. Yeah,
I remember because cuz the video we did
with you last year, uh what is it at
220,000 views, something like that. Over
200,000, like way over. Um and since
then you've had a couple hundred emails,
right?
Yes.
Of people just asking you. In fact, this
week I had a girl who I know from she
lives somewhere in the community message
me on Facebook asking and she's ran into
you at a restaurant. It was about her
brother. Um but she messaged me and like
can I get his phone number? And I was
like I don't have it. But like like
people are like
dealing with this and and it's people
that you just visit in your own church.
You have no clue what they're going
through. I mean I've had I don't know if
you guys have but I know I've had
demonic experiences happening. Um and
you know we talked about a little bit on
on the last show. In fact last night I
have a thing that's called um hypnogogic
hallucinations. I think that's what you
call it where it's like if you when
you're just about to go to sleep,
it's either as you're about to go to
sleep or as you just you just wake up
and you start hallucinating. It's it's
actual like a, you know, medical thing,
you know.
And so last night I woke up
and normally I see, you know, I see
weird things and it's it's actually
caused by stress. It's like a thing in
your brain. But last night I saw um a
person in front of me, blonde hair, and
it reminded me because that day I was I
was going through a video that we did
with Mikey where he talked about demons
and aliens are often seen with blonde
hair. Freaked me out. Called in the name
of Jesus and it disappeared. And I was
like, is it demonic? Was this a
hypnogogic hallucination? I don't know.
But the name of Jesus, like you talked
about, there's power in the name of
Jesus.
Yes. It makes you wonder how many how
many people that have that have certain
things going on that are labeled like
medical issues,
how many of those are actually, you
know, demonic harassments or or
Yeah.
you know.
Yeah. The other thing I wonder about is
in the US I've often wondered there's an
author named Neil Gim and he uh wrote a
a book or or a series of stories that
was made into a TV show and in this show
there are characters called new gods or
new American gods. The in the list is
very interesting because when you look
at what's happening in other countries
versus what's happening in western
society,
it's pretty fascinating how, you know, a
worldly author can recognize these
things as gods.
And
then it makes me wonder like are these
the things
in the demonic realm that we're being
possessed by? It could be,
you know, there's at least that
possibility. So, they are Mr. World, the
leader of new gods, representing
globalization and modern capitalism,
which I don't, you know, every financial
system I think that man sets up in this
world has problems. Even if it's better
than other options, it's like choosing
the lesser of two evils, right?
In in capitalism, you always have the
risk of greed,
right? So, it's it's not without it's
not perfect.
Media, a shape-shifting goddess who
embodies our obsession with television
and film, often appearing as iconic
figures to manipulate people.
And you think of like, well, we have
this whole culture of advertising here.
One of the most common ways to sell a
product is to use a celebrity or a
notable figure to advertise. There's
technical boy, a young volatile god of
computers and the internet struggling to
control his powers, right?
Um then there's other ones representing
money, drugs, and other aspects of
modern American life. I'm like, well,
this is this is kind of fascinating.
when when you're in other cultures,
they're not necessarily dealing with
those same kinds of things, right? And
Paul says that, you know, speaking of
his time in place, the things they
sacrifice to demons, they sacrifice or
the things they sacrifice to gods, they
they sacrifice to demons.
Yeah, that's right. And so it it's made
me wonder like is this, you know, it
seems like even though this guy is
probably more likely writing for the
other side, is this like an a window
into what western society is really
dealing with these new gods?
I think you said it's not necessarily
happening in other cultures, but
not the same way, but I I
I think it is. So if I look at Cambodia,
you have your traditional culture and
the traditional connection with the
demons.
Okay.
And but now you have the young people
that are very techsavvy.
Oh, okay.
And so they are maybe not so affected by
the traditional way that demons impact
them, but now these modern gods uh ways
that demons are reaching them. So you've
got both levels there. Yeah. So there's
a documentary that we did many many
years ago called Sudology. It was about
media on the brain. And there was this
long clip in the beginning. I think you
guys you were with little light. Yeah.
Right. When Sudology Sudology came out
of
Scotty and I was kind of volunteering at
that point. So I was kind of loosely
like I knew when it was coming out and
they were working on it and all that.
So, there was a set where they had, you
know, like almost like a dollhouse with
mice and little TVs that the mice were
supposedly watching. And on the TV,
there was a video clip. I think it might
have been an Hulu ad that they were
showing where they basically just openly
described this is how we're trapping you
through our media and our television and
how we're we're we're enticing you and
you're just stuck. and and they had like
this like green slimy thing going over
someone's head and just pushing the ad
towards the TV and but you're gonna do
it anyway, so enjoy the enjoy the show.
And I think as much as that was satire,
there's truth in that.
And I can just imagine obviously there
was a it wasn't like the green thing was
an actual demon. It was CG. But that's
kind of what demons do, you know?
They're like, "Here's your addictions,
media, um, social media, pornography,
alcohol, whatever, whatever floats your
boat, and let's just push you in it, and
that's how we control your life."
Yeah.
So, I one of the people that contacted
me after the video last year, uh,
he wanted to understand better what was
happening to his wife. She she had gone
to a Pentecostal pastor and asked him to
pray over her so that she could speak in
tongues.
Oh, okay.
And then after that, she would sit in a
chair at home and her mouth would move
and sometimes she would make strange
noises and she would write
and he sent me some pictures of what she
had written. And it's almost as if she
was channeling
uh and and she was writing down a list
of sins, but next to the list of sins
was abbreviations for the body parts
which the demons supposedly attached to.
Interesting. Now, I was a little
skeptical on the body parts,
but probably a week after I received
this, I was dealing with one of our
girls in the orphanage who was having a
panic attack and she was experiencing
pain in the upper right chest
and having difficulty breathing and I
rebuked I assume this is demonic,
rebuked the demon in her and instantly
she went unconscious.
Wow.
And this happened on three occasions
now.
Okay. Uh and when the demon left, no
more panic attack, no more pain. So
about a week after I received that list,
I'm
uh at a prayer meeting at our church.
She was there. On leaving the church,
she has a panic attack on the steps of
the church. That's what I'm going to
call it, a panic attack. Um and so
again, I rebuked the demon immediately.
She went unconscious. I continued to
rebuke the demon for a few minutes and
then she came around. She's fine. So, as
we walk back to her orphanage house, I
was praying to the Holy Spirit, "What's
the problem?"
And we're talking at the same time, and
I heard the Holy Spirit say to me, she
has a spirit of abandonment, an evil
spirit of abandonment.
What does that mean, a spirit of
abandonment?
Well, her mother put her up for foster
care
when she was very young. And so there's
always been a scar there because she was
sort of abandoned by her mother and she
doesn't know why.
And so I'm hearing this from the Holy
Spirit and almost at the same moment she
talked about the pain of being
abandoned.
Wow.
So there's this connection there.
Uh so I when we got home I prayed with
her and then I went back to my home very
interested to check this list. Mhm.
And so I go down the list, find
abandonment, and it said the point of
attachment for that demon is upper right
chest,
and that's where she's feeling this
pain.
I don't know if this is real. I did
check with someone else who um has some
experience in that area and they said,
"Yes, demons have points of attachment."
And
interesting found that really
interesting that
uh
demons are not possessing in this case
but they're attaching to the outside and
you talked about the green slime pushing
people.
So those attachments they can be
persuading people to do things either
creating pain, fear or speaking to them
in their thoughts. So I'm curious this
this spirit of abandonment is this
because there's many people that have
been abandoned.
Yes.
Is it become a spirit of abandonment
when it's
I guess held on to dwelt upon as in it
starts to become your identity? It could
be uh as I explored with her, there was
some anger and resentment still standing
toward her mother
because she doesn't understand why her
mother did this.
Um and so, you know, we talked about
forgiveness.
Yeah.
And pray that Jesus would help to heal
that wound
and help her to have forgiveness toward
her mother. Uh it was interesting she
also expressed
um sympathy toward her mother at the
same time.
Yeah.
Well, she was not understanding why she
was abandoned. She there was some
sympathy for her mother because there
must have been a a legitimate reason.
She just didn't understand that. So I
think it's the
it's probably the anger
that the demon's actually using, but the
the
root cause is the abandonment and
dealing with the abandonment and what
comes out of it can bring freedom.
Yeah.
So I know we talked about this a little
bit on the last show as well, but I want
to bring it up again because I think
this is a very common idea. um that
there's a demon for specific things like
there's a demon for anger, there's a
demon for addiction. It you're nodding
your head. So, I'm guessing that's true,
right? And and how does that work?
I believe so. In fact, in the back of
this book, there is about 180
different things uh which I believe that
demons can use to um justify their
presence,
not necessarily possessing a person, but
justify the right to harass them one way
or another.
And about 140 of the 40 of these
actually came from the uh what this lady
had written down.
Oh, wow.
Wow.
I just add it to it.
That's quite a list.
It's a little bit frightening when you
look at it because you think, well,
yeah, I do that, too.
So, so, but how does this work? Because
not everybody um that I saw one in there
gossip.
Mhm.
Everybody gossiped at some point and you
know, the spirit convicts you like,
Lord, I'm sorry I did this thing. You
know, why is it that some people get
possessed or harassed when they do that
and some people don't? Is it simply the
attitude of humility right after? like
you're you might be struggling with it
and wrestling with it, but you're always
coming to the Lord saying, "Lord, help
me with this sin."
Yeah. I think if you're doing that, then
the demons aren't so likely to give you
trouble because you have Christ on your
side. But if you're dwelling on it or if
you if you're not dwelling on it, but
you're not wanting to do anything about
it. You're happy in that that sin, then
basically you're leaving the door open
for evil spirits to come and harass you
or worse possess.
That makes that makes sense. It's like
embracing your sin versus struggling
through a sin and realizing this is a
problem and I don't want to end my life
and like wrestling with God to you know
so since the last video as I've
counseledled with people online uh two
of the very common problems that are
coming up are pornography and
masturbation.
Okay. And that these seem to be key sins
that people are having difficulty giving
up.
And the demons are using every
opportunity to to trigger
this sinful action. And so they keep
falling back into that sin.
And so what has your counsel been?
Confess it.
Okay.
Ask God for help. Mhm.
Uh I also counsel when it comes to
pornography at least to to see if you
can find a
um spiritual
counterpart who can you can be honest
with and they can pray an accountability
partner. That's it. Yeah.
Yeah.
And so that
once you share it with somebody
uh who's spiritual and going to be
praying for you, then it's it's easier
to to stop, I think.
And because not only are you thinking
that, well, this is wrong in God's
sight, it's like I I promised a friend
I'm not going to do it as well.
Just helps a little bit.
Yeah. Yeah. What are some common things
besides those two that that when holding
on to it is when the demons are allowed
to come in?
Anger,
hate, unforgiveness.
They're sort of all related.
It's very strong. Um, one of the coming
out of the video last year, I had a lot
of people from Africa contact me
and most of them seem to it was either
generational curses or curses that have
been put on them by somebody during this
lifetime.
Oh wow.
And it was impacting in many ways. Some
of them couldn't hold a job.
Wow.
Some of them couldn't get pregnant. Some
of them couldn't hold a relationship.
every time they started to develop a
relationship with someone of the
opposite sex, it would just fall apart.
So, what's a generational curse?
Uh, it's passed down from one generation
to another. And it may have been that
the families being cursed or because of
the family's interaction with the
spirits. Of course, in Africa, there's a
lot of spirit worship. And
uh there are many, we could call them
devil priests, witch doctors. Um so
there is um it's generational spirits
that go from one level to another and
one generation to another and unless
that is broken those curses can
continue. So I've been encouraging them
to claim the blood of Jesus Christ
right
to break that curse
and uh to pray for the Holy Spirit to
fill them and help them to have healthy
relationships with people
help them to be able to hold their jobs.
But you mentioned um somebody else might
have cursed them. So I'm guessing that
somebody who is strong in the Lord like
a strong faithful family who is
surrendered to Jesus can't be cursed,
right? Like it has to there has to be an
open door for that to happen.
Yeah. Well, I think like the girl with
the smartphone,
right? Um I if there are no open doors
uh if every day we are desiring Christ
to live his life through us then Satan
he can oppress us but he can't harass us
or um possess us.
And so I see a difference there for
those people who
are having a problem like this then they
need to confess their sins. They need to
do deep confession where they're asking
the Holy Spirit to reveal anything in
their life. that they need to confess
and then daily close the door.
Paul says, "I die daily."
That's right.
So, it's dying to self daily, dying to
the desire to sin daily by going to
Christ and saying, "I want change in my
heart."
And what about trauma? We talked about
the pain of abandonment.
Yeah.
But trauma, I would say it's human.
Trauma is another big one, especially
from sexual abuse.
Okay.
And so many people also have written to
me and they're having demonic problems.
they've been abused in their childhood
or later in life and quite common there
is to be hearing voices. So there's just
voices speaking to them basically
trying to discourage them bring about um
fear and depression
and often putting suicidal thoughts into
their minds.
break.
Hey, subscribe to
[Music]
It seems like, you know, when I'm
listening to you and and I've heard
other people talk about this that a lot
of things distill down to
your attitude towards another person
based on the pain that they've caused
you
and how you how you respond to that
is seems to be what what can open a door
or or keep a door essentially closed.
Yeah. And quite simply, it seems that
most people
that wind up dealing with things is
because they have unforgiveness.
Yes.
You know, they're angry at somebody and
they don't forgive them and because of
that it it leads to, you know, some kind
of oppression.
And um that's that's really a powerful
thought.
And when you think about the things that
Jesus says in the Bible about
forgiveness,
you know, you see how much you see in a
in a very tangible human way how
important that is, you know. So it's
it's I think it would be good for people
to reflect like is there anybody in my
life that I am not forgiving that I'm
that I'm holding a grudge against that
I'm that I'm angry at and really
evaluate that because you have to ask
yourself at the end of the day do you
want that thing that person is it worth
giving up the kingdom
you know to be to hold on to that anger
and and unforgiveness so much that you
wouldn't possess heaven. You'd rather
hold on to this.
Well, we know that um there's there's
there's going to be people who will be
this close, but they're not going to
make it. And that's not because anything
because what God has done or God is
holding them back or or you can even
really love Jesus, but Jesus like give
me everything. Surrender everything. And
for you to hold on to anger, um, you
know, it's it's he wants us to forgive
and that can, like you said, or or
anything else like we've talked about
addictions, you know, is it really worth
that extra bottle of beer or that extra
YouTube videos that give you some
dopamine for 15 minutes to then hold on
to that over and over and never
surrender. And when it comes down to it,
it's like Christ, like you've never
given me your all. And it's and it's a
balance, too, because he's not saying
like, "Oh, well, you know, um let's say
you die in a car crash tomorrow." And
he's like, "Well,
you know, you uh you you weren't perfect
yet." You know, he's he's saying like,
"No, I I just I just want to know that
every day you're you're willing, like
you said, you're struggling against it.
You're not just saying, "I'm just going
to take it all and whatever. You can
have all of this, but not this." You
know, like like willingly. There's
difference between that and fighting
against it. and then he sees that.
So I think when when you're daily
inviting Christ into your life,
then you may have your falls through the
day,
your sinful falls,
but if your your desire is that Christ
live in you, then you Christ counts you
as perfect.
That's right. He covers you.
Even though you may have sinned, he he
covers you with his blood, his
righteousness. Um and and this
this needs to be stated so that some
people who are being oppressed by demons
on a daily basis, they might be hearing
voices daily. And there's one lady I'm
working with, uh she's hearing voices
daily and she's praying, she's giving
her life daily to Christ, but those
voices aren't going away.
And just because those voices are there
doesn't mean that she's not saved.
Right. Right. because she's surrendering
her life to Christ on a daily basis. The
demons are persisting, hoping to
undermine her faith in her salvation.
But if she remains faithful, then she
will be saved. And
I'm glad you mentioned that. That's a
hopeful, powerful point because so many
people could give into despair.
And uh it's it's fascinating. I I have
dealt with two instances in my life
where I had to make a choice whether I
was going to essentially hold a grudge
against somebody
or not. And uh the first time I was 18
years old and I had
almost graduated high school, not quite.
And I got a phone call from a relative
and uh they proceeded to tell me, "My
parents have been lying to me my whole
life. Um, you needed to know all these
things about my biological father." And
I mean, it was it was my 18th birthday
when she called me. Actually,
I was so upset. For two weeks, I would
go to school and I would be okay. But
whenever I'd come home, I would break
out in hives for two weeks. had a hard
time sleeping, you know, a hard time
eating, all this kind of stuff. It was
just And I was angry. I was upset. I was
at the lady or your family.
I was upset at at the relative and I was
upset at my biological father.
Mhm.
And eventually
what I had to work through was because I
had, I guess you could say, I had the
opportunity to take on that abandonment
identity,
right?
because I had never met him, never spoke
to him
anything. And so it was like, you know,
did but but I had been told that when my
mom was pregnant, um 7 months pregnant
with me, that he had left or kicked us
out.
And
I made a choice because I said, I can't
live like this,
right? This this is going to eat eat me
alive. And I said,"You know what? God
has always taken care of me. I've never
lacked. I've never wanted. All my needs
have been met. So even if that person
was never in my life,
I'm good.
You know, I have my heavenly father."
And it was in knowing and realizing that
that I was able to say, "It doesn't
matter what's happened over here."
Mhm.
I'm good.
And all that stuff went away. M
that was affecting me. All the anxiety,
all the anger, all of that, it all went
away. But for a while it was, you know,
it was it was intense. It I had to go
through the same thing again 18 years
later.
Um close to the same time only that time
it had flipped and it was about my
stepdad,
not my biological father. So all this
anger and all this kind of stuff came
back. And so then it was I realized the
lesson that I had learned before is like
I know where this road leads and this
will eat me alive if I go down this
road. So I just had to say, you know
what,
I'm good. I have a heavenly father. It
doesn't matter what's happened.
God is the one that takes care of me. So
even if my my earthly relationships with
my earthly father's biological or step
or whatever aren't good or perfect, I
still have God. Mhm.
And that was the only thing that that
really carried me through that is making
God my stronghold and my and my father.
Mhm.
So we we could say like the emotional
baggage we have that's like food for
demons
and it attracts them.
But if we unload that baggage, if we
give it to Christ to deal with, we ask
him to bring healing into our lives.
Yeah. where there are scars from
whatever happened
and then that baggage is that garbage is
swept away
and the demons don't have anything to
feast on.
Amen.
Do you deal with all of all you said you
have like 180 demons I would say?
Oh, in here.
Yeah, in the book about 180.
Okay. So,
I haven't dealt with all of them though.
But um for someone who's experiencing
like trauma versus addiction versus the
spirit of abandonment and pornography,
do you deal with would someone need to
deal with all of them the same way? Is
it like one solution fix all?
There's one solution. Go to Christ. If
it's a sin, confess it. If it's a sin
that's been done against you, ask for
the power to forgive the one that's
sinned against you and ask for healing.
and and Jesus can do that for you.
And then it closes the door. And and
with demon possession and harassment,
often that's all it takes.
You don't have to have a deliverance
session where you're ordering demons out
in the name of Jesus. Um once the person
knows Jesus and the power of Jesus
allows the power of Jesus to work in
their lives and to resolve the issues in
their lives,
then the demons no longer have an excuse
to be there.
Yeah.
And they just go away. Mhm.
And that's a much better way to deal
with it.
It's such a paradigm shift because we
seem to re be repeating the same
mistakes of our first earthly parents,
right?
The natural reaction, natural sinful
reaction is cover it up and hide it.
And God says, "No,
I'm a God of transparency. I make all
things known.
Uncover it. Mhm.
You You uncover, you confess it, you
bring it out in the open,
and then he says, "I'll take care of the
covering."
Mhm.
Let me take care of the covering.
Yes, that's a good point. It's like,
it's exactly what he did. He took care
of the covering.
Yeah.
But he made sure that they had to bring
it everything out in the open. He's
like, you know, I already know you're
naked.
Adam, where where are you? But like, he
didn't say it because he didn't know
where he was. He I know where you are. I
just want you to know that I'm looking
for you.
Yes.
You know, he's looking for us and he's
just waiting for us to come to him.
It's not a geography question for Adam.
It's a it's an emotional connection.
Yes.
Question. Like, where are you? Where are
you in relation to me? You're far from
me.
Right.
So,
I like the the biblical reference that
says that God will put our sins at the
bottom of the sea.
Yeah.
And I think of the Mariana Trench. When
I think of the bottom of the sea,
it's like 12 kilometers. how many miles,
nine miles under
the ocean where man cannot
pretty much cannot go.
And so God is trying to say, look,
when I deal with it, it's dealt with.
It's gone forever.
Yeah.
We have a friend who's a pilot and he
says, you know, the Bible is very
specific in that it says from the east
to the west, you know, your sins will be
removed far from you. He's like, notice
it doesn't say north and south. And
there's a specific reason for that. Cuz
if you go east, when are you going to
get west?
Mhm.
True.
It's never going to happen. Right.
Cuz once you go east, you're always
going east.
Right. Right. But but but isn't the same
thing with north and west?
No. North and south. It's not the same
because they're two distinct points
points with like
east and west. You can only go one
direction.
That's good. So your book um you told us
off camerara that some interesting
things happened when you started writing
it as well. Can you want to tell us more
about it?
Well, before I started writing it um
when I started counseling with people
that were contacting me because of the
little light studio video and at the
same time I was in Europe speaking on
spiritual warfare and on mission. Uh, I
get news from my wife that she's sick.
Mhm.
And so this is like two weeks before I'm
supposed to get back home to Cambodia.
When I get back to home to Cambodia and
I I thought she might die.
She had pneumonia really bad. She'd take
a medication. It hadn't helped. Um, and
one morning shortly after I returned, I
sat down for my morning devotional time.
And often I'll ask God, "Where do you
want me to read today in the Bible?"
And I asked that question and I heard
Ezekiel chapter 24.
Okay?
And Ezekiel 24, I didn't know what was
there. I've read it before, but I didn't
know what was there. And so
I'm reading through and I get to verse
16 and it's and it's God speaking to
Ezekiel and he says, "Today I'm going to
take away the love of your life."
Referring to his wife and I don't want
you to cry. And I'm it's like that hit
me. God, you sent me to this chapter.
Are you trying to tell me something?
Oh, wow.
And uh
I had some hard time there surrendering
if this was actually God trying to tell
me what he wanted to do.
Uh was I willing to trust his will
over my desire for her companionship?
Because we've been married for 42 years.
Wow.
And we happily married. Um,
and I, yeah, I prayed, okay, God, if
this is what is best for her eternal
good, if this is what is best for your
kingdom,
then
I'm okay with that. But I can't promise
I'm not going to cry.
Yeah.
And and so I I surrendered her to him.
Next morning I woke up, the first thing
I did, checked to see if she was still
breathing.
And she was. Praise God. So I think God
was putting me through a Abraham Isaac
kind of test to see whether I was
willing to surrender the one who was
dearest and closest to me in this life
apart from Jesus.
Yeah.
And I made that surrender. And
she got over her pneumonia, but she
found out that she had um an autoimmune
disease that was attacking her kidneys
and her lungs. And that's ongoing. And
so she's also
at the same point, God, if if you want
me to rest until Jesus comes, take a
sleep, okay, I'm okay with that. I'd
rather be with my family, continue in
ministry, but if you think that's best,
okay. And so she's at peace with that.
Um,
and then when I started writing this
book, Fallen Angels.
Yeah.
Two weeks after
there was an accident that killed my
grandson and he lives next door
and
without going into all the details. It
was almost certainly in a demonic attack
because it was really freaky the way it
happened.
And
that was very hard. It was hard on his
father and mother. still is. And it was
hard on me because I I loved him very
much. Uh we had a lot of good times
together.
He was 5 years old.
He loved the Lord. He loved to sing my
BL BL and other songs about Jesus.
But the way I had to deal with that was,
"Okay, God, we ask you to be their
shield and protector,
but most of all, we want God to uh deal
with their salvation."
Yep.
And God I believe demons did it. They
caused the accident. They caused him to
die.
God could have prevented it,
but we want him to do what's best for
the eternal good of our grandchildren.
And if God saw fit to to let the demons
do that,
uh, knowing that Mikey is sealed
and that he will be resurrected at the
second coming of Jesus,
then I'm okay with that because I will
have him for eternity.
Yeah.
From the demonic side, I think they made
a mistake.
for two reasons.
One, because now they no longer have an
opportunity to tempt him. Therefore,
they cannot take him away from the Lord.
He is with the Lord forever
in that sense.
And second, they angered both my son and
I.
Yeah.
So, we are more determined than ever to
rescue captives, Satan's captives, and
bring them to Jesus for salvation.
Amen.
Amen. Did it ever
I guess were you ever tempted after
seeing a couple things like that like
maybe I shouldn't be writing this book
or maybe I should stop writing the book?
No, it worked the other way. It's like I
can see the devil does not want me to
speak on this area and I can see the
devil does not want me to write this
book. And because
he's making that known to me, I'm going
to be more persistent
because I know that well, if I if I
finish this project, it's going to help
people know God and receive eternal
life, and therefore, I'm determined to
finish it no matter what.
Do you have any um I guess uh well, we
probably already covered it. It's it's a
relatively simple formula, but do you
cover that aspect in the book? Like this
is what I've done, you know, to help
people be delivered or this is what you
should do as like preventative
medicine, so to speak.
Yeah. Well, I guess we've covered some
of it. First of all, avoid sin.
Yeah.
Go to Jesus and ask him to to live in
your life so that you have the power to
avoid sin.
Mhm. And if you have sin in your life,
confess it
and repent and ask Jesus to change your
heart, to take away the sinful heart and
put in a heart of flesh, a heart of
love.
Um,
and
thirdly,
ask Jesus or claim the blood of Jesus to
break any rights that e evil spirits may
have over your life. So you if you've
had a problem with pornography, you've
effectively signed a contract with
demons
to give them access to your life.
So you claim the blood of Jesus to
cancel that contract. Yeah.
So they no longer have the right to work
in your life.
And if the demons are coming and
harassing you,
whether with thoughts, uh with things
that you're seeing, physical harassment,
then rebuke them out loud. Rebuke them
in the name of Jesus and command them to
leave you alone and do that out loud
because they can't read your thoughts.
Right?
So if you want them to know what you're
thinking, you have to verbalize it so
they can hear it.
Yeah. And I I had a girl, a lady write
to me just last week and she said she
watched the video. She read the book uh
which we promoted on the video which is
called set freeing Jesus
and then she put the principles to
practice in her life and the demons
left.
Wow.
And they came back a while later and she
rebuked them in the name of Jesus and
they left and they haven't come back.
Praise the Lord. So
power in the name of Jesus.
Amen.
So if you're suffering in this way, then
you can self-d deliver
by following the simple form formula
which is repentance, giving your life to
Christ and asking him to work his power
in your life and then and letting the
demons know that Jesus is now Lord of
your life and that you claiming his
name, his power
to expel them, ban them.
I just want to point this out. You know,
we as Christians know there's power in
the name of Jesus and and that's amazing
and we we point it out, but think about
it practically, right? Like demons are
the most powerful entities in the world
below God and below his angels, but
above humans, right? Like there's nobody
more powerful. tanks, your weapons,
nothing.
No person
at any point. I can't if I there's this
demon, I can't just say Keith Felipe
does nothing.
Yep.
But then just the name to say Jesus and
they run
like that is powerful. That is really
powerful.
You can see that happened when Jesus was
on earth alive. I mean, Mark 5 talks
about the man with the legion of angels
possessed. Just the presence of Jesus
alone frightened the the demons
so much that they went to Jesus and
said, "Please have mercy on us." Right.
The demons asking mercy to Jesus simply
by Jesus being there.
Yeah.
You know, shows how powerful. Yeah.
The other thing I think is amazing about
that is
we do that in our own context which is
English, but it works in any language.
All languages. Yeah. Jesus.
Any language. Whatever you, you know,
know Jesus to be. He knows
he knows who you're talking about. If
you're praying to him, he knows
Yeah.
who you're referring to.
And the demons know who you're referring
to. So
that's pretty it is very powerful. You
can't It's not just any name. It's only
one name. But we have to make sure we
don't play with the name of Jesus.
Yeah.
So use it to
to meet our needs when we want our needs
met.
Yep.
But then
gumball machine.
Yeah.
So sometimes I'm not sure I talked about
this case last year, but this lady
wanted freedom from demons, but not
freedom from their power.
And so the demon, she'd be delivered
from the demons, but every time she went
back to using the power, the demons came
back.
Oh boy. M
and so we can use the name of Jesus to
cast out a demon, but we also have to
separate ourselves from
the desire to use that power. In her
case, um I I know she levitated. I'm not
sure what else she was doing, but there
was accessing the power, the demonic
power for her own pleasure.
And and a lot of people,
they want to they want to be free of the
sin, but they want to keep the pleasure,
the sinful pleasure.
And so we have to surrender all. Yep.
And then Christ can work powerfully in
our lives and set us free.
Amen.
So I got two more questions for you.
One, where can they get the book? And
two, what would you say to people that,
you know, they might have some fear
like, should I read the book because I
don't want to get possessed, you know?
First of all, where can you get it?
Well, actually, both of these books,
right?
Both of these books are available on on
Amazon and other book major book
sellers. So if you just type in fallen
angels or when sacrifice is gain into a
search uh engine, it'll come up and show
you.
Okay.
Um and then uh if you are having
problems in your life,
it's very possible that demons will come
after you
because they don't want you to read the
book
because the book will lead you to
solutions to those problems. the book
will help lead you to Christ and and so
I before reading the book
go to Christ and say I want to know you
better
please protect me while I'm reading this
book
otherwise it's likely if somebody's
already having problems it's going to
manifest itself more greatly at some
point
so I mean the book is just I think it's
the catalyst to their anger
Yeah
because they realize deliverance is on
the horizon and they don't want you to
be delivered and and It's Yeah. I mean,
if if you're worried about it, start
reading the Bible, too. Yeah.
You got that now before you order Tim's
book.
Yeah.
Crack that open.
If you don't have it downloaded until
you find
Yeah. So, yeah. No, great answers, great
stories. Thank you so much for sharing
and thank you for writing these
experiences down to help people.
Yeah. Because, you know, so often we we
wander through life kind of aimlessly
thinking, uh, you know, what do I do?
Yep.
I need help. And we don't think of the
obvious solutions all the time, but
it's interesting how people will will be
intrigued like, hey, that sounds like a
problem I'm having. I'd like to read
that book. And then they
discover the solution. So, thank you for
writing and sharing your experiences and
uh sharing the actually what is very
simple solutions to deliverance and and
being free from the things of this
world. If you like this video, like,
subscribe,
and hit the notification bell so you
know when we launch new videos
and drop a comment below and we'll try
to get back to you if we can.
What?
Say that again. No.
No. I don't know what to say.
[Music]